okay so army of thieves is a prequel to
zack snyder's army of the dead taking
place six years before scott ward and
his crew tried to steal 200 million
dollars from a casino in las vegas we
watched the origin story for ludwig died
or as we learn he's really called
sebastian unpronounceable last name now
i'm just going to be calling him dida in
the review as it might get confusing
just jumping back and forth but it's
safe to say that he came out of army of
the dead as one of its most popular
characters in this origin story we
learned that he grew up interested in
safe cracking and that he used to break
ludwig models in his spare time he
created a comic book character named
ludwigdider and that's where the name
originated from zack snyder is pretty
much creating a brand new snyder verse
centered around the characters that we
saw in army of the dead and it's great
that netflix have given him this
opportunity warner brothers really
dropped the ball in my opinion by
shutting his vision down with the dc
characters and i'm glad he's getting
free reign to basically do what he wants
with a brand new ip because these
characters aren't really established
names there's no studio execs or parts
of a fan base that say they should be a
certain way and it means that the
director can tell the story that he
wants to without people forcing reshoots
and basically getting this studio into a
position where they have to cg out brad
cage's mustache now in this video we're
going to be going over the plot of the
film how it ties into army of the dead
and also discussing what could be
happening later on in the universe full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to watch it and go beyond this
point then it's going to be too late to
switch sides please hit the thumbs up
with your best eat a punch impression
and if you enjoy the video make sure you
subscribe as you're always safe with me
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into army of thieves
okay so as mentioned earlier the movie
takes place six years before the major
events of army of the dead this actually
aligns with the opening of that film
which showed the undead overtaking vegas
and we then got a big time jump so
everything is kind of happening
concurrently to the events of that film
and throughout it we get news reports of
zeus's rampage as well as little easter
eggs for what's to come in the timeline
now not only are the key objects that
appear throughout but we also see images
of tanaka who ended up hiring ward to
break into his vegas casino in order to
take his money back before the city was
destroyed in the first news report at
the bank just before the camera cuts you
can also see the news reporter who's
killed later on running through what i
believe is a casino behind the zombie
adida focuses on we can also see what
looks like a bride and the bride zombie
was of course a big antagonist in army
of the dead now he opened with dina
making a youtube video about a locksmith
named hans wagner after his child and
wife died wagner ended up creating a
series of safes that were all based on
richard wagner's legendary ring cycle in
case you don't know these pieces are all
based on nordic legends and this is why
they're named after characters like the
valkyrie and so on wagner created these
saves as magnum opus and after building
the four he made one final uncrackable
one that he locked himself into this was
to contain his anguish and grief and the
true meaning behind it is that he wanted
to be trapped in there with his family
and all of the memories that he had with
them unable to free him from it the safe
was dropped into the ocean with wagner's
body still in it never to be seen again
now throughout the movie we watch as
dida is recruited to crack three of
these four safes and the final one is
what he breaks into during army of the
dead throughout the film he's plagued by
visions of zombies killing him and at
one point he dreams of being grabbed
from behind by an undead version of
wagner after he infiltrates his
masterpiece though this doesn't happen
in army of the dead dida is apparently
killed after being grabbed from behind
by zeus now i say apparently because
snyder has been doing interviews to
tease the next film and we now know
it'll be called planet of the dead he
said that dida could still be alive and
that his return may or may not involve
him meeting back up with gwendolyn now
it's said in the movie that the constant
dreams might be prophecies and it could
lend itself to the time loop theory that
exists around army of the dead it's all
a bit complicated so i want to address
it later on in the video but he
seemingly dies after sacrificing himself
to lock van der rohe in the safe much in
the same way that gwendolyn sacrifices
herself to save him we'll get into it
later on but dear ends up joining an
underground safe cracking tournament
with the first code being that you don't
talk about safe club keep your secrets
safe otherwise you'll be locked out hey
now what's a thief's favorite fruit
strawberries like straw like robberies
and strawberry no moving on now it's at
this point that he meets gwendolyn a
korea criminal who introduces him to her
crew this is made up of karina a master
hacker that leaked pirates of the
caribbean too now in real life whilst
two didn't leak the fifth installment
did 10 days before its release hackers
stole a copy of the movie from a
production company in la and they held
it to ransom the group demanded 80 000
from disney and threatened to release it
online if the house of mouse didn't pay
up mickey doesn't negotiate with hackers
though and the company never paid up
however this is a nice little nod to
that real life story in the flashback to
her past we see her with her little
brother and we learn that he's probably
in jail which is used as leverage on
karina later on in the movie now there's
also a getaway driver named rolf and
real life action hero brad cage brad or
rather real name alexis was bullied at
school and he changed himself into an
american movie character whose name is
based on brad pitt and nicholas cage
together they set out on the ring cycle
quest and throughout gwyndolin very much
puts the idea in deeta's head that she'd
love to break into the fourth safe she
even mentions going to vegas to crack it
which of course sets it why dida is so
happy to be doing the job in army of the
dead the two promised to break it
together so he's very much carrying it
out by going on that seemingly suicidal
mission there's also a bit after he
cracks the first safe where dida shouts
i'm invincible several times which i
kind of think might be a nod to when
boris did it in goldeneye boris said it
just before dying and dida would also
seemingly die right after cracking the
final safein army of the dead there's
also the third safe siegfried which
basically tells the story of dida's
journey when cracking it dida says that
siegfried faced his fear and after his
darkest trial he met his loved brother
hilda the two fell in love budding got a
damn rung siegfried died the safean army
of the dead is called gotta damn rung
and this speech very much foreshadows
the character facing his fear of zombies
before he apparently dies after opening
it godda damn wrong was also about a war
between mortals various beings and gods
and this somewhat ties into army of the
dead there was of course the human team
attempting to enter vegas the robot
zombies the normal zombies and zeus was
named after the king of the gods now
brad believes he's gwendolyn's boyfriend
even though there's nothing between the
two and when she and nida get close he
ditches him during a job brad becomes
the bad guy and after they rob the final
save he catches up to the pair and holds
them at gunpoint however we learned that
the firing pin has been removed but if
you're paying close attention to the
movie then you'll have already known
this during the first job when they're
in the van tina panics that brad has a
gun but gwendolyn points out that she
removed the ammo and just lets him have
it because it looks cool this is because
he previously shot an interpol agent
named ella craw who only survived
because he had a hip flask that blocked
the bullet karina is captured by
interpol who've been on the hunt for the
thieves for years and she gives up their
plan after her brother is used as
leverage delacroix arrests brad and rolf
and he then heads after gwendolyn and
dieder the pair finally kiss and they
almost ride off into the sunset together
however just as they're about to escape
delacroix catches up to them and both he
and gwen have a standoff at gunpoint
because dida is the newest member of the
crew and he just wants her brad karina
and rolf she negotiates his escape she
promises to get out and find him and
that the pair can crack the god of damn
ring together but as we know he just
does it himself on the boat dina finds a
passport with his comic book name put in
place and also a ticket to the same
place that gwen was going it broke his
heart thinking of all the adventures
that he and her could have shared
together and he knew that of all the
people in the world that he wanted to be
with her the most he states that they'll
be reunited in the vault of the gotta
damn rung and this very much mirrors
wagner who locked himself away in a safe
to be with his family though adidas says
they'll be together we of course know
from army of the dead that they aren't
in a relationship during that movie the
film then ends with an extension of the
scene from that film in which steeda is
presented with the job for the safe
though we know he goes to this and
seemingly dies there are also a lot of
metaphors that come with it the goddamn
rung was seen as wagner's final chapter
and he describes it as a doorway to
another realm i kind of take this as
being heaven for the character and
should deeda definitely be dead then
when gwen dies the pair will be reunited
in the afterlife together at this
location there's also a weird code lice
throughout the movie and shout out aaron
s bailey for sending me through some
screenshots of it i'm not sure exactly
what this entails whether it's a
watermark or whether it's something more
but it is very strange it appears in the
scene in which dida says goodbye to gwen
and also the one where he's recruited
for the safe so maybe it ties into their
relationship somehow they of course
missed out on a lot of things by getting
caught but as we know army of the dead
also has a number of things going on
with it too it is possible that the film
somewhat ties into the time loop theory
and that explains how dieter is able to
see his death way ahead of time now in
case you need a refresher on that theory
at the midpoint of army of the dead we
watch as the group head into the casino
and here they find another crew that
have all been killed as they head to the
vault they come across corpses which all
carry the same clothing as they do and
something suspicious seems like it's
going on van der rohe theorizes that
they're stuck in a time loop and snyder
teased that the version we watch is the
ones who get the furthest due to the
radiation within the nuke it was thought
that the entire thing was a loop with
the alpha zeus leading to van der rohe
who had an omega tattoo on him he would
then go on to spread the disease and
potentially the whole thing could start
again i don't know how much weight there
is to it but snyder has discussed it so
i definitely think that it's worth
bringing up now potentially the time
loop could start here then go into what
we see in the film and then loop back
around all of the characters in this
movie outside of dda seemingly survive
past army of the dead so it is possible
that they might even end up popping up
in feature sequels too now as for the
sequels and prequels that are coming we
know that we're getting an anime show
called army of the dead las vegas which
will take place during the initial
outbreak it will tell the story of how
cruz and scott ward met and what they
went through in escaping the city it's
also going to explore aspects like the
ufos and also the robot zombies so yeah
i'm very very excited for it now in july
this year it was also confirmed that
there will be a sequel to army of the
dead and that'll go into production
after snyder finishes up his next
project which is called rebel moon on
wednesday it was announced that this
will be called planet of the dead and
it'll chronicle the zombie outbreak
destroying the whole planet it's going
to continue past the events of army of
the dead and we'll show what happens to
van der rohe after we last left him
potentially he landed at an airport and
this spread the disease across the
planet and that would explain why earth
ends up being overrun there were also
ufos in the opening of the movie so the
planet might not even be earth and it
could be somewhere in space that's
completely covered in zombies sonata's
next movie is called rebel moon and
though it hasn't been announced as being
connected to this who knows it might
actually tie in somehow and we'll see
how the zombies get from one place to
the other we don't know yet but there's
a lot of things to look forward to now
as for my thoughts on the movie i'm
still kind of weighing up whether i
prefer to over army of the dead but in
all honesty they're two completely
different types of movies this is the
sort of deconstruction of the heist
genre whereas that's a deconstruction of
a zombie film and what would basically
happen if the undead came back to life
there's even moments in this where they
talk about heist movies and what
typically tends to happen in them and
they poke a lot of fun at the
conventions whilst also having a blast
with the story it's not exactly the most
original heist movie i've ever seen but
they keep things fresh with the
characters and also the varying
locations i hope that we get origin
stories for all of the characters and it
would be great to see more stuff in this
universe which netflix definitely seemed
to be enthusiastic about overall army of
thieves was great and i definitely
recommend that you watch it if you
haven't and because of that reason it
scores an 8 out of 10. now let me know
your thoughts on the movie below and as
a thank you you'll be entered into a
competition on the 30th of october in
which we're giving away three copies of
the mcu phase 3 box set all you have to
do to begin with the chance of winning
is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the movie we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
say that to you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of lock and
key season 2 which will be linked on
screen right now that's another great
netflix show that we had a lot of fun
talking about so hopefully i see over
there right after this if not then thank
you for sticking through this video hope
you enjoy the rest of your weekend and
you take care of yourself it's friday
[ __ ] i'm out peace